what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a jubilee video
couples therapy but the therapist is
seven years old before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos wow i'm trying to go to england
guys please subscribe
uh each and every one of you seriously
helps me so much
on youtube do you see happy couples mr b
surprised his girlfriend with a hundred
thousand roses
hundred thousand roses
how did you see the world when you were
a kid
we brought in three couples to receive
counselling from kid therapists to see
if a kid's perspective could guide the
couples through their relationship
struggles oh wow
i think a therapist is someone who helps
other people people or couples if
they're having a bad day or are in a bad
or in
or if they are in a bad situation
hi my name is isabelle hello hi this is
ruby i'm andrew nice to meet you nice to
meet you too oh my name is evan hi evan
thank you hello are you gavin yes so how
are you guys feeling today you're
feeling good well i'm feeling nervous
i've never done it same here
we have a couple things that we might
need to work on
um
oh she's
she's ready
i'm very very different from my wife
here kathy i love video games a lot same
hair
but that means i also like to stay at
home a lot and just kind of do things
you know on my own and play video games
with my friends yeah so i prefer going
out so i like hanging out with my
friends outside i like going out hiking
picnic you know the park yeah i actually
have a park
i also like to ride bikes exactly guys
always want to stay at the house let's
go do something hang out yeah so our
problem is that i like going out and he
prefers staying indoor so every weekend
we have you know trouble deciding what
to do and we always argue about it wait
i have an idea um you know pokemon go
it's like a video game but you can walk
around you can try that out
first of the week this kid's playing
video games that he likes and then the
other 50 of the week
then you have to
do what she likes
okay
50 50. i like that a lot right now it's
80 video games and 20
going out
so we have to split it halfway down
there yeah
he's so mad he's like no this is
terrible so
what do you guys disagree on
what do we disagree on
do you have instagram
no we disagree on instagram sometimes i
don't know i i sometimes have a problem
that you don't like to post me on your
instagram you should yeah who you're
with like you should want to post them
yeah
sometimes it feels like he tries to hide
me
i don't think that it's much of a big
deal if you want to contact virtually
you should
use sex messages face time or
zoom yeah
zoom me
yeah we could i guess huh how can i help
you guys she did not like that answer
she really did it
i get a little grumpy when i have a bad
day yeah i come home and i do put it on
her sometimes
and i don't know how to deal with this
sometimes like i don't know how to make
him not be grumpy do you know how
we can fix that
well um
i
i would think probably like if you guys
have like other rooms you could go to
one room and then you can go to one room
okay and then when you cool down you can
tell her all about it
yeah that's a good idea i don't know why
i think of that we never thought of that
suggestion
i feel like we sort of disagree on
things when it comes to like jealousy
and like fear of losing someone like all
relationships end
and it is going to either end in breakup
and death or divorce are you afraid that
i will lose i will leave you no
just wondering
so
if if you guys had to choose would you
propose right now
oh
oh
oh look at
look at his face
oh my gosh he's like oh why is he doing
this to me why is this child doing this
to me
just straight up pull out a ring and
propose right there
that
that's like
you have to plan that so i would i would
say no no like if you had it planned
though oh if i had a plan of course yes
but like as of right now just be down on
my knee that wouldn't make sense
well oh she's not liking this answer she
is not liking this answer i think of it
like a rank
like karate you have like this belt
you're at the second highest ranking and
then when you get married you go to a
black belt
okay so you think you'd be like a level
up
yes okay
i do have something else someone else's
advice with though okay so at home we
live together
and
i do everything around the house and
he's great at cooking so he does cooking
but i do everything else do you think
that's fair amount of chores how can we
make that more fair
um you do 50 50 of the house and he does
yeah and then he does the other 50
yeah but cooking is a lot of work you
have to chop the stuff you have to buy
the stuff i cook every single day but
you need cleaning this this kid is not
buying it he is not buying it three or
four days i go in the kitchen every day
that's true yeah you have a point i have
an idea a first teacher not a [ __ ] okay
first started eggs even i can make
scrambled eggs you just i'm turning the
oven on
get a pan wrap the eggs
done thank you for teaching so he should
teach me how to cook i should help him
cook more and he should help me clean
more yes i love that
and my sister don't really get along oh
no
yeah and i'm not sure why
this as sisters we know
we know you know i don't know how to
talk to her if she doesn't talk to me
so how do you think i should try to
befriend her
probably get her like a gift and tell
her how you really feel like oh i think
you're not like
being nice and probably say something
like that
okay well do you think
she would want to talk to me though
probably
give her flowers and a card or like a
teddy bear like most people do kind of
oh okay she loves nightmare before
christmas oh you see yeah you should
have told me that well there you go okay
on youtube do you see happy couples oh
yeah mr b surprised his girlfriend with
a hundred thousand roses
hundred thousand roses that's good like
if she wants like a necklace or ring
you should save up to buy what she wants
okay i think he does do that
he surprises me a lot so
i think that was good advice he's
meeting those requirements right now
well i appreciate you taking the time
out to sit down and talk our problems
with us
you're gonna thanks
those games okay bye bye
nice meeting you too thanks tom you know
the crazy part is these kids gave decent
solutions
like seriously decent
out of ten i wouldn't give them a 10. i
wouldn't go that far maybe like a six
all right
oh they're so cute
that they trust in each other and to
love each other and not cheat on each
other i think love is a level beyond
friendship it takes
um a lot of hope and a lot of
responsibility and trust to make girl's
relationship how do these kids know what
cheating is i did not know what cheating
was at seven years old
my best suggestion for games among us or
freddie made fun among us is like oh
there's oscars
um
this was a fun video
these kids i love videos with like
children in them oh gosh
um
let me know guys what do you think of
the video
sorry i messed up my camera don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time